[Music]
i don't think that you could
consider like that yeah like marriage as
a standard yeah because to be honest
we want to be together for life but we
don't know if we necessarily want to get
married
[Music]
what does compatibility between a couple
mean babe
compatibility is very much a choice you
choose
to be compatible with those differences
you choose to find
compromises between them time is
obviously not a legitimate factor you
can be compatible in two weeks
and a lot of ways has to do with having
aligned values and aligned beliefs
like we are very much not alike we just
have so much fun together
i think because we're different i think
it's good to see your partner as
somebody that makes you better than you
would be without your partner that's
that's a big part of it my name is john
i'm keisha we're newly married nice
thank you congratulations
just being married for what four months
that's when we started living together
it's like oh
i really dislike how many socks i see on
the floor but i accept that
every relationships have their arguments
minor disagreements here and there but
some major ones too yeah we've known
each other for eight months and we have
been officially dating for about six so
i'm actually moving this summer i'm
going to law school in a different state
you're gonna go with it you're going to
houston oh my god wow awesome
we met in october and have been dating
since then yeah he had something on his
hinge profile about composting
and i was like that's the guy for me if
there's been a human rights violation or
harm to the environment we really think
about it with every single thing that we
do
we've been together for two and a half
years and we're engaged
we went to the same university and had
the same major and had mutual friends
and then we met on tinder
lily and joseph both seemed really
compatible they went to school together
they have similar careers and the fact
that they have made that step
towards marriage my name is eric i'm
jessica
and we've been together for two and a
half years a very fun
beautiful not stressful tuning yes it's
been great
no problem love you so much we're
definitely opposites of track
you like very fancy things and i like
street burritos if i were to put out
there a street ranking right now
i would say one same
no two but i think i would go honestly i
think
three four five no shade i was which
four and five i feel like they're
married like that's
okay okay you're married which is points
but you're a new marriage
which is like how many figuring out your
yeah
because you just started living together
i would put us at number one
i've been really impressed with with
these two i want to rank them three
what do you think i feel good about good
about three three
four for the married couple and i'm
sorry i really like you guys
but five when we first started dating we
actually had no physical intimacy for a
long time
which was a little bit different i think
we're both physical touch and quality
time people
like this this makes me melt absolutely
lily and joseph like you can tell he's
like obsessed with her
because of our faith we agreed that we
did we wanted to save like sex until
after marriage which
made like after marriage a lot more
special after that
i would probably put keisha and john and
fifth honestly
so hard but what compatibility is to us
is so different we've been having a
sexual relationship for
two plus years like we know each
i think eric and jessica are the most
compatible they're just comfortable with
one another they don't mind
teasing one another exposing each other
i think you guys are number one
i think we could put ourselves in two of
them as three
maybe i would put them four and then
five even though you guys were fantastic
they made everyone a good couple to make
it hard i'd be disingenuous if i didn't
rate us number one so
you guys at two i'm gonna put you guys
at three y'all for four
and then you guys were five it hurt us a
little bit when we
said that we agreed to um wait until to
wait until marriage to move in together
even though in that decision we are
compatible with each other it's not very
normal i guess in society wait who is
the couple that met online during
pandemic
also both of you yeah so one
two three four and five
being a covid couple not to knock on
them or anything but they haven't
melded communities and that's something
that's so key
in a healthy thriving relationship i
think now that you know each other's
rankings
you guys have to decide number one
literally in a minute and that person
needs to stand here
i'll just say real quick i feel super
confident staying here because four out
of five people said three
yeah yeah i feel like we're our average
well we were ranked two like two okay
[Music]
lillian i remember more my own so that
helps you guys
they were very much like we are the best
so it kind of was like okay you are the
best
all right sure you know if in this
ranking
you were to change places or like switch
things up how would you do that you
already know
man i'm in the front bro you already
know i don't want to like oh you guys
you guys are not compatible i don't even
know what that means
you guys are all persuasive charismatic
people i'm not saying we aren't either
but it just feels kind of like i think
you guys are super cares about it
you're very sweet that's fine
i have a tendency to to be biased
towards married couples of course but i
think i'll shut up because i think i was
overruled there
so sorry all right no input for me this
is good
[Music]
i think compatibility transcends you
know simply having shared interest i
think
growing together almost versus just an
interest
the extra things in a relationship other
than just
sort of love or lust or passion do you
think there's a difference between how
same-sex couples view relationships
versus how straight-up
relationships yes obviously like when
the straight couples were questioning
each other like
marriage and engagement was like a big
part of it and like we might value other
things and like marriage hasn't always
been a privilege we could even do
i feel like this couple right here
definitely deserves to be number one
in fact i had the most compatibility i
really liked them
chemistry is really good eric and
jessica had an amazing connection they
bought seemed super super
comfortable together it didn't seem like
they were putting up any friends for
everybody should be
ready you guys are going to go there
i would put the married couple second
yes we were thinking that too
i think like you said their values
really do mesh super well i don't know
they just had like
a confidence about like their
relationship they were very down to
earth and they didn't really brag about
it
i'm happy with them as number two but i
would put the married couple number
three
i think they were friends as well as
partners
[Music]
for me personally about like these like
pandemic relationships is like
they have experienced hard things too
but so is every other couple
the couple that talked about being vegan
and low waste talked about their
lifestyles together but we didn't hear
much about the
couple that is moving about how their
lifestyle is so i don't know how they
might be when they're in the same house
you know were the couple that had the
shared interest
of not having a lot of waste and being
vegan for me compatibility
isn't necessarily having all the same
interests or like being into the same
exact things
for those reasons i would rank the
couple that's going to be in long
distance pretty soon as number four
i also really liked how they were like
so willing to fight
to get to a different squad and i think
that really shows i think we're number
one
the way they like talk to each other and
interacted just seemed like it was easy
for them let's switch them
yeah okay
and i think i'm happy with like having
these two couple at four and five
because they met in the pandemic so like
all the clubs are close like
you can't really meet people there's no
temptations there's like nothing there
are you all happy with this ranking yes
yes
[Music]
as soon as the other couples came in we
were like we are going straight to the
end it's an easy thing to be like well
they've only been together for this long
so they may not truly know each other
i think we got demoted to two because
eric and
jessica they seem very authentic and i
love that about them as a neutral
observer
i probably would have done the same
thing when they switched us up from this
two spot to the one spot
sweet awesome because that's something
i'm working towards every day i only
know myself
and i know that we're in the number one
spot it's such an emotional decision
because you want to fight for
everyone everyone wanted to be one every
couple should feel like number one like
that's fair and that's like a good thing
i just think it's so neat to see like
other people in love honestly
technically now
you